so we'll move on to this there's a
shake-up at the Department of Homeland
Security it's going far beyond the
resignation of secretary Kirsten Nielsen
the White House fired the head of the
Secret Service and the number to DHS
official yesterday Citizenship and
Immigration Services director Lee
Frances ISNA is also expected to leave
along with the department's general
counsel White House senior adviser
Stephen Miller is said to be the driving
force behind these very dramatic changes
major Garrett is at the White House with
new information on Miller's role in all
of this major good morning it's quite a
story it's quite a story good morning
internally the White House has been
divided over immigration policies for
weeks with the president's building
frustration colliding with existing law
and federal court challenges it all came
to a head late last month when the
president abandoned any bridge building
and sought confrontation first within
his own administration and quite
probably eventually with Congress our
systems our countries the president has
privately fumed for months about the
increased flow of undocumented migrants
and congressional opposition to
tightening Asylum laws or speeding
deportation one of the great tragedies
that is going on in our country today is
the loopholes in our immigration laws
speech writer and immigration hawk
Stephen Miller won a crucial internal
battle in late March when the president
gave him control over immigration policy
and homeland security personnel senior
advisor and son-in-law Jared Kushner had
been lobbying mr. Trump to work with
Congress in pursuit of new laws but the
president refused and gave new power to
Miller who's looking to revive the
family separation policy in closed ports
of entry at stake is the question of
whether or not the United States remains
a sovereign country Miller and the
president now appeared determined to use
immigration to motivate the president's
base and portray Democrats as soft on
security the mass illegal immigration
across our border is a direct
consequence of Democrat supported
loopholes in the process the president
is creating massive unrest inside the
country's third-largest agency one with
crucial obligations ranging from
domestic terrorist surveillance and
Prevention to cyber security to the
Secret Service even the Coast Guard
Republicans are fretting about the
turmoil and praising the stability
Neilson represented our grasp of the
issues and dedication were major assets
for a department I know a director sis
not it would be a real mistake if they
go that far down into the bureaucracy to
fire good people like that
adding to the president's border
frustrations yet another court maneuver
to block administration policy a federal
court judge in California late yesterday
said the policy the administration has
where asylum seekers are held in Mexico
Mexico waiting their hearings is now
blocked on Twitter last night John the
president said that decision was out of
control Wow major a lot of shake-up
there thank you so much major Garrett at
the White House